let me make my point
hey guys and welcome back to the Leia
Heil pen show I'm here back with my
brother Gideon and today we're going to
be talking about the amazing news that
Andrew and his brother Tristan Tate have
been released from prison so we're going
to be giving you our honest opinion and
our reaction to this news now before we
jump into the video please don't forget
to hit the like button and subscribe as
we're going to be bringing you a lot
more of this kind of content and as
promised we did say that we're going to
be following the story and keeping you
up to date so I want to kick this off by
firstly saying we're so happy that the
tapes have been released and finally
justice has prevailed and it actually
shows that they are innocent I think
what's been so crazy for me throughout
the last three months was the fact that
it's not innocent until proven guilty
anymore it's guilty until proven
innocent and I just found it so
heartbreaking because I actually had a
lot of friends became really mad at me
because they said that I supported a
which isn't true and I think people
unfollowed me even professionals
unfollowed me because they said Leia how
can you support somebody like this and I
think now people like myself and other
people that were supporting The Taste
feel somewhat Vindicated yeah actually
this is a very good point you're making
but testing testing one two three making
my appearance can you hear me so oh so
no I like this this is good this is cool
anyway anyway let me make my point let
me make my point a lot of Leia's friends
some old school friends who who she
hasn't heard from years reached out to
her saying oh my God you're supporting
this kind of man you know I can't even
bother to say all the different things
he's been accused of because this will
just get taken down so it's like oh
you're supporting this kind of man you
know we're no longer friends and it's
like bro you haven't even spoken to her
in like years how you were never even
friends what do you like I don't care
what you say so all of these people
randomly reached out to you which is
really interesting a lot of them were
guys a lot of them were girls as well
um you know probably feminists uh blue
head septum piercing this kind of
individual you so it's so interesting
they just came out of nowhere and
everybody had an opinion on it when they
don't even know the bloody guy they
don't even know the man the whole idea
of Andrew was guilty until proven
innocent and he was slandered online by
all these people we were in so many
different spaces oh my God the Twitter
the Twitter oh my spitting so it's the
passion it's the passion all right let
me let me say what I gotta say you know
I'm on the platform now all right so the
thing is we were on so many different
Twitter spaces and wow those got heated
we we held we hosted a few of our own
and we were on
and we held our own defending Andrew
Tate
um because we know what kind of
individual he is and he's a good man and
all these women random women like who
who are you would just come up and say
these random things which is just
completely untrue and made up it's very
interesting because the very people that
accused Andrew of all these awful things
are men and if we just believe all women
that is literally how you destroy a
man's life so by following their logic I
wonder how they would feel if a woman
one day came and accused them of such an
awful crime and then we all started
holding them to the same standard of
which they held Andrew which is guilty
until proven innocent to me it just blew
my mind it's like you're mad at me as a
woman for not believing all women what
if somebody came after you wouldn't you
expect your expect your friends and
other women that know you like me to
stand up for you as a man I mean again
you you know I know you agree with this
but I think you do reach a certain level
of like Fame whereby having women accuse
you of things is inevitable it's just
going to naturally happen even if you
are as good as gold it's a true sign of
someone's character when hits the
fan and lots of people are saying bad
things about you or you need people to
come to your Aid and they don't and I
saw so many people and even Andrew he's
made comments about this they've kept a
close eye on who has been saying good
things and sticking up for Andrew and
staying true to their word and who
hasn't so it's just the ultimate
character of somebody and it's
disgraceful for the people who were
claiming to be his friends just to jump
on the Andrew Tate hype get the clout
get the podcast that they wanted but
suddenly when he's held in custody they
decide oh no we don't want to touch this
now this is bad for my brand it's bad
for my image you know it's ridiculous
um
yeah yeah should we name names let's
name names no let's name names when I
met Andrew and Tristan for the first
time there was another person there and
that person
um the Tates were hosting the tapes were
hosting him so clever Leia memory is so
clever
it's like a dog no I'm just saying
you're so clever
I'm just saying that um when I met the
Tates for the first time they were
hosting this guy who they seem to be
really cool with the taste literally
were very hospitable to him they gave
him a place to stay in Romania and then
when Tate was in jail I saw this guy on
Twitter bad-mouthing him and it really
shocked me I mean I unfollowed him and
then he unfollowed me um but actually
that's the name that I need to let
Andrew know after you make this and he
said because Andrew wants to know all
the people that were rude yeah text him
tell him every every single snake out
there on the internet because there's so
many but sorry sorry carry on I don't
mean to cut you no no that's it it's
just you know it's just shocking really
that like people who you think of your
friends and then are just not your
friends and we'll talk you know bad
things about you when you're in jail so
that's uh something that also happened
yeah and I I replied to one of Andrew
Tate's tweets um he was talking about
you know when he came out let me do that
again
[Music]
[Laughter]
he came out
Andrew Tate and Tristan being released
reminds me I put a tweet out that went
viral the other day of When Donald Trump
got elected people are so angry right
now all the feminists the blue head
people my choice
the people who just hate Andrew take the
male feminists even you know those kind
of weird old men who uh for some reason
don't like Andrew I don't know why he's
only like like Destiny I just discovered
Destiny yeah oh yeah oh yeah sneaker was
telling you about Destiny he wants to
debate you yeah funny yeah apparently
Destiny's been like hitting me up like
and I have no idea but yeah he's like
that guy that guy's a weirdo again he's
a blue haired weirdo anyway the point is
they were so angry just like when Donald
Trump got elected punching the air
fuming listen this guy's done nothing
wrong he's a free man and he's only
empowering men women and children all
across the world to do better in their
lives yeah like Leia has spoken about he
just you know he talks in a very
exaggerated sometimes hyper hyperbolic
way is that the word
you have a hype to be hyperbolic is that
a word
I think it might be hyperbolic no he
talks in he talks with Hyperbole and
that's fine how how else do you think
you get attention on the internet you
need to Market yourself and you have to
say things which are controversial in
order to get people's attention but you
should really pay closer attention to
the message he's actually saying which
is to improve your life go to the gym
take responsibility these are all normal
things which were spoken about even like
10 15 years ago but now it's like oh
that's toxic if you're being responsible
for your life or going to the gym and
trying to make money it's toxic it's
hustle culture these were normal things
this is why certain people don't like
Andrew he kind of exposes the truth
within them I think overall it's amazing
that Andrew Tate is out of jail Andrew
Tate has been a net positive for society
women like Bitcoin it's like Bitcoin
wait can I stop Andrew Tate has been a
net positive for society yes like
Bitcoin because look of course he's good
for men but I think Andrew is amazing
for women we women like masculine strong
competent powerful men every man that I
meet now wants to be like Andrew Tate
and I am not complaining they're all
using Andrew Tate as this role model
this icon to become like him either way
it inspires so many men to level up in a
way that us women really admire I
personally think that all the men have
become really feminine they're not very
competent they've become very weak and
we don't like that so now all these men
they want to be like Andrew I think
Andrew Tate is a massive net positive
for society and I'm just so happy that
he's been released and can continue to
spread the beautiful word of masculinity
that us feminine women love
wow I uh I don't really know how to top
that I mean I think you said that pretty
goodly like that that was that was well
said I'm just looking through his
Twitter right now he's still got the
homeless look going on he hasn't he
hasn't chosen to get rid of the the
beard he hasn't shaven his head as well
obviously usually he's got a skinhead
haircut I think the home I think the
home us look he's rocking the homeless
look he looks good oh you like the
homeless look well yeah well he he looks
like he's just come out of a war that's
hot like ah I see I see okay so guys out
there if you got the hobo homeless look
going on muscle not skinny homeless
muscular homeless the musk apparently
that works the women like it yeah I
think he looks better if you just you
know clean shave and get the hair done
again maybe he's like like still living
through this he feels like you know what
I'm in war mode you know he's got it
reminds him of the horrible times that
have just happened so he doesn't forget
and he stays in that kind of like War
mode which is really important to strive
in masculine excellence and go forth
very righteously and courageously but I
was going to say one thing hold on this
photo is actually really funny I'm gonna
put it up uh we're gonna put it up on
here wait where can we put it hmm
but yes okay it's it's here so this is
really funny it looks like has someone
edited this picture on his team
black he looks more black than he
usually does well yeah yeah he just
looks caramel black I don't know the
point is look at the beard it's like
this it's like the damn Bulgarian like
beard they've given him the Giga Chad
bed yeah it's like overly done it's it's
uh it's very very shaped it's like Dan
Bilzerian or what's the guy in 300
or the Gerard Butler character um King
leonitis it's like the king leonitis
beard thing going on uh whoever edited
that book that's kind of funny but yeah
listen Leia said it better we can come
back here now Leia said it best the
guy's an absolute net positive for the
world thank you Andrew Thank You Tristan
we appreciate everything you do more men
need to hear this more women need to
find men like this yeah so it's all a
net positive uh Leia any closing remarks
no just on on the point of like him
looking still homeless
a psychological standpoint I don't think
he he can just shave and go back to what
he was before jail like something's
happened to him he's been through a
transition he can't just go back to what
he was and pretend it never happened I
think it's going to be like a slow
process I actually spoke with him the
other day
um we were just messaging and he seems
he seems good he seems like in a good
state of mind and healthy which is
really important and really great to
hear
um and to be honest I am just I'm I'm
riled up I'm angry yeah we all are we're
all pissed off it pissed me off this
guy's done nothing wrong keeping him in
for three months yeah so I'm just so
excited to see what Andrew does I really
hope he continues to take on The Matrix
and I think those are my final words I
just I support the Tates and I think
Andrew's great
do your thing yeah yeah like now I can
like do you think
[Music]
all right well that's the end of our
video thank you so much for watching
we're going to be keeping you up to date
on everything that's going on with the
teeth the red pill space we also have
some amazing podcast guests coming up
which I know you guys are going to love
those are dropping in just a few weeks
so please make sure to hit the like
button and subscribe so you stay up to
date on all the incredible things
happening on the channel and and there
might be oh there might be what's
happening part two of the Andrew Tay
interview happens oh yeah well yeah well
we're gonna try and make part two happen
I don't know whether he's allowed to do
a podcast while he's on house arrest but
um we will definitely text him and see
if he'll do party with us
all right bye guys bye